[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro d'
envies de lecture avec mon invité franck
lanot bonjour bonjour vous êtes
professeur de lettres vous êtes
romancier vous êtes aussi c'est pour
cela que vous invitez le préfacier de la
correspondance qui vient de paraître
entre gustave flaubert dont on s'apprête
d'ailleurs à fêter les 200 ans de la
naissance il est né la même année que
napoléon et morin finale et et ivo
tourguéniev et cette correspondance
s'appelle je n'ai pas les nerfs assez
robuste pour vivre dans ce mode là et
c'est publié aux éditions le passé alors
franck hanoh cette correspondance ou
d'une partie 1 une petite partie même de
la correspondance de flaubert qui est
immense et beaucoup de lettres à georges
cents à maupassant à zola à sa maîtresse
louise colet évidemment mais pourquoi
cette correspondance justement avec un
écrivain russe mais qui est le plus
français au fond des écrivains russes y
vivent est d'ailleurs dans les yvelines
à bougival on peut toujours voir ça sa
maison et qui compte 235 l'aide pourquoi
cette cette correspondance ou par est
elle particulièrement intéressante
alors oui quand vous l'avez dit fort
justement ça n'est qu'un petit aspect de
cette immense masse documentaire qu'est
la correspondance de flaubert
le passeur d'ailleurs à éditer là une
partie avec maupassant une partie avec
avec lluis colet alors vous avez raison
il alex effectivement assez particulier
cette rencontre entre eux ce que vaut
pas son appel les deux géants le gérant
flaubert et le géant aux ménages mais
elle était vraiment une baleine c'est
barack et ils se sont rencontrés par
hasard dans un dîner et ils sont passés
d'une espèce de 2 2 pourrait dire de
confréries de d'écrivains échangeant
d'aider des idées sur leurs oeuvres à
vraiment on voit d'ailleurs très
nettement comment on va passer d'une
amitié à ces cons passer à quelque chose
qui deviendra une sympathique une vraie
affection et puis après la vraie amitié
littéraire de tout ce que ça comporte
de grandes de grande intensité en
complicité familiarité aussi tout en
gardant le vous vraiment très
intéressant de voir c'est en fait on
voit évoluer cette cette relation mais
on en voit quand même une aide de deux
permanences dans du respect dans l'eau
vient il du respect de l'un pour l'autre
d'ailleurs et d'admiration
il c'est vrai aussi que cet échange de
lettres qui va durer de 17 ans ça
s'étend sur une période qui est très
intéressante puisque ça va de 1863
jusqu'à la mort de flaubert en 1881 et
c'est évidemment une période historique
très forte puisque il va y avoir la
chute de napoléon iii la commune la
république quelles sont leurs aux
vabrais revenir sur les jugements
notamment de flaubert sur la société qui
sont qui sont très très forts on s'en
doute mais est ce qu'ils ont eu des
positions politiques affirmé alors leur
position politique s'est aisément de
penser par rapport aux critères qui sont
ceux d'aujourd'hui
on dirait d'aujourd'hui fait que
flaubert est une espèce de anarchiste de
droite si vous voulez reprendre une une
formule oxymorique du xxème siècle c'est
à dire il détestait bourgeois dont il
fait partie il est très hostile à 12
pieds le discours de la plaine ce qu'il
appelle la plaine c'est à dire ce
discours on dirait un peu gauchiste
gauchisant qui consiste à vouloir
inventer une société idéale il il est
finalement quelqu'un de très très
critique il est bien sûr pas engagé et
encore moins engagé sartre lui a
lourdement reprochée panoplie il n'a pas
déploré les morts de la commune
il prend pas position pour les grandes
causes humanitaires ce sont ce sont des
esthètes et finalement leur véritable
engagement je dirais sedar et là comme
l'autre disent finalement c'est l'art
c'est la culture qui doit sauver le
monde
c'est là la beauté littéraire ces
anciens qui sont sur le plan politique
c'était de lisier
sont mis dedans ni de sainte-thérèse
tous les deux à la politique mais ils
sont vraiment toujours des militants il
ya une chose c'est amusant mais quand on
se téléphone il paraît que la phrase
qu'on dit ou le bus verts du temps c'est
et où est ben et au délire dans cette
correspondance des bisons ou est ce que
vous êtes
alors alors c'est vrai qu'elle a un qui
est plutôt lhermitte les réserves et de
croatie c'est flaubert et puis loot qui
plus dans la société qui est organisée
qui voyagent qui revient en russie
d'ailleurs est souvent souvent flaubert
demander où est ce que vous êtes vous
mettez le doigt sur quelque chose de
très intéressant qui m'a frappé mois à
la lecture de cette correspondance
j'ai pensé aux boxeurs quand deux
boxeurs se battent s'ils sont trop près
il ne va pas échanger des coups parce
qu'il n'ya pas d'allonger s'ils sont
trop loin évidemment le coût ne portent
pas puisque la distance ne le permet pas
il faut trouver cette bonne distance et
la chance qu'ils ont eue finalement
c'est que leur correspondance ne soit
pas de proximité
s'il avait été voisin de palier ou s'il
avait été voisin de rue eh bien il se
serait vu alors que là il ne se voit pas
parce qu'ils sont plusieurs à nous alors
quand est ce que tu viens et quand je
suis content joie mais je peux pas venir
et cette distance sec extraordinaire va
créer le besoin de correspond c'est à
dire de faire des mots voilà et tout ce
qu'il perd lé pourrait dire en chair il
le gagne on en cours ou en papier
allez pour ça qu'elle est passionnante
mais c'est vrai geek ici well as ils
doivent venir des coeurs c'est très
intéressant parce qu on a par exemple
les horaires de train pour aller baril à
moins aideront à croissy fait c'est
toujours ça il ya des choses formidables
dans ses correspondances parce que en
dehors des choses très importantes
il ya aussi tous ces détails qui sont
qui sont merveilleux alors il faut venir
quand même au jugement sur la société
les notamment les jugements de de
flaubert on le sait un robert vomissent
échos contemporains et quand je dis vomi
le le terme est presque approprié parce
que il y avait souvent des thèmes qui
ont trait au corps
je vais je vais citer j'ai toujours
tâché de vivre dans une tour d'ivoire
mais une marraine de merde
en bas les murs à la faire crouler ou
encore je ne voudrais pas crever avant
d'avoir déversé quelques pots de merde
sur v semblables ou encore alors manom
le patri devient de plus en plus
stupides alors là on reconnaît
évidemment flaubert d'organier flux
contredit pas totalement mais est ce que
c'est pour ne pas accéder excédent cette
colère ou parce qu'ils partagent ces
sentiments je crois sans faire de piques
analyse de camping mais je crois
qu'effectivement quant aux rennais fait
beaucoup plus modérée il est beaucoup
plus posé flaubert se laisse aller à à
tout ce que sont ces paroles ou des
sites et effectivement le célèbre lettre
dans laquelle il veut y déversait ce pot
de merde sur la société
oui il ya chez flaubert d'ailleurs
christophe reymond h a choisi comme
titre la jeunesse sous les yeux je n'ai
pas les nerfs assez robuste pour vivre
dans ce monde là et on a tout le mépris
revu ce monde laser cette société là
finalement on trouve chez flaubert une
grande critique du bourgeois c'est quand
même quelque chose qui est constant je
trouve à cette littérature de la
deuxième partie du 19e
on le voit chez chez quelqu'un comme
rimbaud évidemment chez baudelaire
chéché mallarmé le bourgeois finalement
c'est l'homme de selommes de l'avoir
c'est l'homme de la matière et flaubert
se veut lui l'homme de lettres l'homme
de l'esprit on peut jouer des airs homme
de lettres et homme de lettres et c'est
peut-être ça qui ressort le plus je
trouve dans leurs échanges alors que
tours de venir je dirais plus et plus
ductile les plus plus sinueux et la plus
volontiers le sens du monde et des
relations que flaubert il est plus dans
la société ausy 1 il vit il va demander
des repas mondain et ses terrasses que
ce que flaubert fait probablement un peu
moins il ya aussi et vous le dites dans
les correspondances ou faire attention
parce qu'il y en a qui
vous à l'écrivain vous parlez de gide
notamment et là vous dites aux contrats
flow baldé il est lui-même quoi ils
étaient guidés
alors c'est tout problème effectivement
de la mise en scène de soi quand on
écrit une lettre à cette époque et qu on
s appelle flaubert et qu'on la destinait
au kenya on imagine bien qu'elle va pas
aller au panier et qu'elle ne finira pas
dans quelques corbeil donc il sait très
bien que c'est une partie de son oeuvre
ça qui est intéressant c'est que il
avait très nettement consciente
il n'écrit pas de mémoire il était pas
de journal intime ou n'écrit pas de 2,2
de carnets personnels sa correspondance
c'est finalement la halle à l'écriture
de soi
la mise en eau du mois de flaubert donc
ils soignent cette correspondance il
sait qu'elle sera gardée donc évidemment
une part on pourrait dire de pause il ya
une part de jeu mais en même temps que
c'est un jeu giroud c'est en même temps
un jeu j e on va faire un petit
calembours facile mais ce jeu c'est à
dire
il exprime par delà le côté joué
finalement quand on joue on y croit un
gamin qui joue la guerre ils jouent à la
guerre il est dedans c'est un chez
flaubert
le tout n'est qu'une espèce de
spontanéité et de sincérité qui apparaît
je dirais peut-être encore plus du fait
qu yves qu'il sait qu'il joue et que son
lecteur aussi va jouer au lecteur en lui
répondant alors parlons peut-être un peu
de la correspondance de la situation de
la correspondent aux halles dans la dans
la littérature
certains disent pas c'est inutile de
s'intéresser au fond à des uns des
textes ils n'ont pas été écrits pour
être pour être publié à quoi ça sert de
savoir que balzac et sur mer j'ai tout
le temps par ses problèmes d'argent son
fils un peu c'est pas une oeuvre
littéraire
c'était mal armé je crois qu'il disait
le meilleur de nous n'est pas destiné au
papier à lettres
kébé et d'autres disent au contraire à
la vérité des écrivains on la voit
justement dans cette correspondance
quelle est votre position
là encore sans être normaux et bien qu
est en vacances mais je dirais que là
peut-être le fond des choses dans la
résultante c'est à dire que on ne
saurait réduire évidemment le une
correspondance fonds tirés de fer d'une
correspondance un texte à proprement
parler littéraire c'est à dire construit
voulu puisqu'elle se fait au fil des
jours néanmoins quand il s'agit de
d'auteurs comme comme flaubert comme
togo nièvre comme l'écran épistolier un
voltaire par exemple on sent que ce sont
des gens qui mettent dans leurs
correspondances une partie importante de
même qu'ils réfléchissent sur leurs
oeuvres il faut aussi voir que la
correspondance est une espèce de miroir
mais pas mon miroir narcissique ou comme
je le dis dans ma préface à me le disent
en être ou ne pas être
non c'est vraiment un mémoire dans
lequel ils se regardent et ils te
regardent également par le biais par la
médiation d'un d'un autre qui est en
l'occurrence ici tourguéniev ou le
destinateur où le risque les dos il ya
une dimension vraiment littéraire et moi
je m'en suis rendu compte pour eux avoir
étudié de près certains textes de
flaubert
ces lettres sont vraiment pas tout
évidemment mais certaines d'entre elles
sont vraiment des débits joue aussi bien
danalyse ne soit que le critique
littéraire se sont tous les deux de très
grands et de très bons lecteurs
vraiment on mesure quand même que son
lit au lit des livres pour apprendre à
écrire dans ciels monde c'est pas
simplement un travail scolaire c'est
vraiment là ils lisent et écrivain il
les étudierai c'est très impressionnant
la démarche critique que qui se fait
jour dans ce sport c'est vrai quel style
peut-être peut-être que je pense pas il
n'y avait pas le gueuloir dort dans ses
correspondances je pense pas mais mais
c'est vrai qu'on on retrouve on retrouve
le le le style de flaubert et puis et
puis et puis sa personnalité parfois ça
n 2 de ses contemporains le problème de
la correspondance aujourd'hui c'est que
c'est un genre fini quoi on va on va on
va avoir des échanges de mails
honte récrie 20 le mail est en train de
tuer deux éléments importants de la
critique lederer qui sont la
correspondance et les brouillons alors
certains d'entre eux supprimés
progression de garde
mais les lions les loups sont tels qu'on
les connaît c'est à dire c'est page
accumulé on voit les ratures enfin
d'autant plus chez flaubert c'est
impressionnant on peut pratiquement
considérer que pour une page 2 de
flaubert il ya dix pages préalable il ré
enfin quand on a fait le jeunot entre
les littératures et ratures il
s'applique parfaitement à flaubert alors
ça oui effectivement là la génération
numérique fait disparaître cette espèce
d'amont du texte vrai ça c'est vrai que
faut s'y résoudre
raison de plus pour voilà pour relire
les grandes correspondance et et je
conseille particulièrement celle là donc
je n'ai pas les nerfs assez robuste pour
vivre dans ce monde là c'est le titre de
la correspondance entre flaubert êtes
organisé e vous presspass et franck
lanot cette audition le passeur merci
infiniment merci beaucoup merci à vous
[Musique]